wow I'm blown away I'm gobs smacked uh
first I would like to thank the
organizers for inviting me to speak at
this lovely
event I had nothing to do with that um
uh this has been a wonderful meeting uh
I'm going to try and uh not mess it up
here at the end uh so
um everyone's been showing pictures of
the birthday boy um uh here's the oldest
baby picture I could find of cir
QED uh so uh as Leo mentioned and many
of you know we have a kind of tradition
in in the group um which is kind of
Fallen by the wayside with PowerPoint
and everything but like people would
bring a print out and we'd date it and
sign it and things like that and so this
is uh a printout that I think Andreas
put on my door it's uh phase of a
dispersive measurement versus gate
charge and he just put the two you know
double question marks like he wasn't
even sure it's this really but it's
period itic and gate charge so maybe
like we're finding the Cooper pair box
with this dispersive measurement and uh
a lot of people have also been asking me
is your birthday today um my birthday is
actually the 24th and uh you can notice
here this this apparently occurred on
the
25th um so this was Andreas bringing me
a 40th birthday present so for all the
people I'm currently working with um
what are you bringing me for my
[Applause]
birthday
um bring yourselves that'll be enough um
and uh you know it was an amazing time
things went rather quickly we had the
dispersive measurement by the March
meeting like in beautiful form um uh we
came back and actually my recollection
is Andreas really wanted to get the
vacuum Robbie splitting by tuning
everything into res I said that's too
hard let's just write this up I give you
like two weeks after the March meeting
to get the vacuum Robbie splitting and
so here it is I guess this was April
maybe we had it working already this is
already like the draft of the uh figure
for the paper and um uh we mailed it off
I think the first person we sent we
showed this to is I sent it off to Jeff
Kimble who had been my instructor for uh
applications of quantum physics back at
Caltech and I'm not sure he ever forgave
me because he was the first to observe
this in the atomic domain and it was
really hard and they never quite got to
as much cooperativity and all that as
these things
um we didn't it was our my first nature
paper we didn't get on the cover of
nature um I don't know if they still do
this they invite you to submit some
candidate cover art and apparently the
mistake we made was letting Dave draft
the cover
art and um so you see uh you can read it
here maybe it's faint uh biology NIH
decides to spend money on physics
chemistry gives up in the face of bio
and physics and so if anyone who was
making the decision was not like a
Quantum physicist we were clearly going
to get
hosed
um uh but I want to say uh thank you um
here's the uh picture of sort of the uh
circuit QED core back in the day um and
it was a wonderful time as you know a
privilege to work with such special
people and uh you know not only cuz it
was early in the lab doing experiments
and things uh and we were still feeling
our way along but also because we were
learning uh this language of uh Quantum
Optics and how to apply it to circuits
and I remember when we posted the paper
many of the people in the field said
think that was a great paper but I
what's a pcel effect effect and why is
there a vacuum Robie and like uh you
know took a while for people now
everyone knows this this lingu lingo um
and I also want to say thank you uh to
uh my partners in crime uh for the last
20 years
uh Steve and Michelle um what a
privilege to work with two of the best
scientists on the planet for all these
20 years in close collaboration and um
uh I don't think that's something that
uh uh you're supposed to expect when you
go into this as a line of work um and
there's been incredible progress we've
heard a lot about it in uh in this
meeting in the 20 years you know we've
gone from nanc to milliseconds that's
called something I forget what
um uh readout fidelities have gone up
we've heard you know really amazing
numbers even uh advancing in the
presentations in this uh in this meeting
uh complexity I guess I have to add a
zero Jerry um thousand cubits um uh size
uh we went from like a 2x7 millimeter
chip to 30 millimet as Andreas told us
um un told us that we've gone from zero
Mass to I think it was 16 micrograms
maybe there's other numbers that are
bigger than that uh the funding I don't
know um uh and I was only thinking about
the uh the academic funding uh let's not
even think about the private sector
funding that goes into it uh but uh of
course there's the headcount and uh so
it's amazing to see all these people uh
everyone working in this space and I
just want to say thank you to the
community uh for all the work you've
done it makes us look good so um thank
you very very much uh okay so that's the
uh uh summary of the modlin part uh what
I thought I'd do instead of giving like
a sort of retrospective of everything
which you heard a much better job from
Steve gerin already um I'd tell you
about some of the recent stuff that
we're doing because after 20 years I
think it's still not getting old circuit
QED um we're still finding out all kinds
of exciting new things uh that you can
do and uh you know one bit of progress
leads to another bit of progress and um
you know in particular we've been
continuing to bust our heads on this
very difficult problem of quantum error
correction and I think we might be uh
actually turning a corner and uh being
able to make some real progress uh but
it's also kind of fun because we've gone
back to basics a little bit and we're
Reinventing even the way we do our
bosonic cubits uh with this dual rail
encoding so uh I'm going to tell you
about uh some of that uh and some of the
results and it's actually uh joint
results because we have a collaboration
between my my lab and the group of shuy
and Steve uh on campus as well as uh the
company in science Park and there's
probably lots of people in the audience
uh uh here from both organizations so uh
we've already heard a lot about uh error
correction um in principle the idea is
easy just redundantly encode your
information uh one bit or one Quantum
coherence uh in uh three separate
physical entities and then if all you
had was bit flips you would be able to
be uh protected uh to first order from
those um the problem is of course now
you have encoded your information in
three cubits which have all three of
them uh errors of their own and so uh
when you think about trying to actually
gain from this uh the ideas you're going
to be gaining exponentially but you're
uh losing as you put in more uh of these
elements so if you think about trying to
reach Break Even you start with just
having some decay of your information
according to whatever the lifetime of
that is and then even if all of the
cubits are as good as uh your best one
uh you're still going to Decay three
times faster but we're told okay if we
can actually measure these errors and
either correct them or stabilize them
remove the entropy in some way or even
just take account of them in the
bookkeeping uh of the way we interpret
interpret the results of the algorithm
um
that'll be okay provided we can measure
sort of quickly enough that multiple
errors don't occur but of course we'll
still be losing no matter what we do uh
but the goal of course of these things
is to really be able to get some
significant Quantum eror correction
gain uh and it's harder than just uh
losing a factor of three in the
beginning because of course cubits don't
just have most of them a single kind of
error they have multiple kinds of errors
and so you need to have a larger code
than just three maybe you need to do the
surface code which is two-dimensional
sort of roughly speaking shy probably
won't like this uh one dimension for
doing uh bit flips one dimension for
doing phase flips uh but uh we're told
it's okay because there's a finite uh
threshold there's a point here where as
long as we can get the devices to be
better so that the error rate is less
than about a percent or so um then we
can uh start to gain from this error
correction and indeed The Logical error
probability will be suppressed U um as
we increase the distance or the size of
this code uh in a way which is uh
exponential in this ratio of how well we
do past the threshold and it's great
because superc connecting circuits and
uh cubits have advanced to the point
where yeah uh indeed even the two Cubit
errors can be uh better than a percent
but they're not a lot better than a
percent uh and so we're still kind of
right on the cusp of this and so uh
things are still pretty challenging um
so nonetheless there's been all kinds of
uh uh amazing demonstrations I'm super
uh uh impressed at the uh amount of
effort that's gone in both on the
industrial side but even in some of the
academic Labs on scaling these things up
uh and you know people have sort of
successfully demonstrated a lot of these
Concepts and uh we're ready to go in
some sense but uh here at Yale our our
strategy has been a little bit different
um instead of trying to scale everything
up and then hopefully getting a little
bit further past the threshold uh we
thought we would do the following so you
know the story I suppose uh to choose a
hardware efficient approach we're going
to use a cubit or something to store the
information that has fewer kinds of
errors and hopefully slower errors to
begin with and we're not going to
basically use the hardware to do the
whole thing we're still going to need to
use of course conventional error
correction codes but what we want to do
is make uh distance three or sort of uh
deal with the uh first round of error
correction in some uh built-in way using
the physics of the devices and if we can
really control uh the propagation of the
errors and all of that then when you
concatenate these things into larger
codes you could uh really be way past
the threshold the basic idea is well
okay if we're at a sort of a percent
level now if we could somehow in
Hardware uh get uh just a distance three
we'd be able to kind of have a a
squaring here of this physical
probability and when you stick that into
your higher order code now you'd really
be past the sort of thresholds for most
of these things so the question is is
there a way to kind of make yourself
first order robust to hopefully as many
of the errors as possible uh so that you
only fail if you have two errors and you
can sort of take a typical performance
of 1% which is similar for readout for
uh uh two Cubit Gates and lot of other
uh initialization and go to uh sort of
numbers that would be orders of
magnitude
better uh and um we also uh had this
really nice talk setting things up uh uh
from shti Puri uh from whom we've
learned a lot about error correction uh
saying that uh not all errors are
created equal note the punctuation in
the title Slide John you're going to
keep track you're going to count for me
um but uh
you know there are uh there's a sort of
a hierarchy of errors and uh some errors
are easier to correct like the erasers
uh you can also benefit if your P errors
are biased and you have a sort of
hierarchy of those things and you really
need to avoid uh leakage okay and um so
uh that's something we're going to try
and uh take to heart here uh building
into the hardware so um the idea here is
we want to Max maximize the power of the
cavities in circuit QED which have a
kind of natural noise bias so uh we've
been working a lot with this flipped
Paradigm if you like of circuit QED it's
not that the transmon cubits are the
fundamental primary uh interest and the
resonators are there for buses or to
prevent uh spontaneous emission uh uh or
to do readout but uh actually we we want
to use the cavities themselves also as
uh information uh carriers and the
reason that we kind of thought that was
good is uh I mean in fact we started on
the 3D cavities to begin doing the
materials investigations for IPA in
2009 um and what we thought is by making
some 3D cavities will get qes of like 10
to the 11 or 12 and then that'll be the
the fiducial we use to measure materials
and everything we can make them be Q of
10 to the
8 uh and get to several milliseconds but
uh still you know there's even in just
these 3D cavities for why they're not
better uh uh than they are currently but
nonetheless they can be uh still better
than transmon cubid in terms of the
lifetime uh and importantly uh they also
have a large noise bias in the sense
that they have very little intrinsic def
phasing it's a linear element after all
it doesn't have any joses injunctions it
has as small a surface participation
ratio as you can uh manage and you know
we can even see that in experiments
where we have this this full setup so
this is from uh the paper by uh Serge
Rosenblum and Phil Reinhold um where
they were able to sort of tune the
dispersive coupling between the transmon
and the cavity and there's a point here
where they turned off the interaction so
that you're no longer suffering any uh
def phasing uh from uh the uh transmon
you're still actually suffering a T1
perhaps but anyway uh this thing had a
uh cavity lifetime uh that uh was uh not
quite a millisecond but then you see it
goes really very close to 2t1 when you
turn things off so from this and from
several other experiments we're able to
place a bound uh and only really a bound
that the intrinsic def phasing time of
these 3D cavities for instance is is at
least 10 milliseconds or longer so
there's a nice uh leverage there and
that's one of the reasons why these
bosonic codes which allow you to correct
for Photon loss should be useful should
be a way to get
gain uh okay so uh again not all errors
are created equal and in particular
these uh eraser errors are a special
kind what an eraser error means is that
uh maybe an an error occurs in a cubit
but uh you have a unique signature
there's something you can measure that
doesn't involve multi Cubit Properties
or stabilizers you have a flag that goes
off that allows you to detect exactly
when and where a cubit went wrong and of
course that means that your uh
information you have is much larger you
can sort of prevent the propagation of
errors and uh it means that uh the
thresholds for example can move much
higher and so this uh work on Dual Rail
and eraser cubits and super connecting
cavities that we're doing is very much
inspired by uh the recent uh work uh
that truy did with uh uh Jeff Thompson's
group uh at Princeton uh in which uh
they looked at uh being able to engineer
a neutral atom platform in which most of
the errors could be then detected and by
that process converted from spontaneous
emission or other kinds of mechanisms
into something that would be classified
as an eraser and this idea of eraser
conversion I think is one of the biggest
sort of practical advances in our
understanding of how you should do error
correction in uh in in uh recent years
um there's another big advantage of uh
having something which is eraser
dominated and that's that because in a
way the errors are a little bit more
classical uh they uh seem like they
scale better uh or to put it more
technically a surface code can for
example correct twice as many erasers
now you don't have to do the surface
code by the way there are of course if
you had predominantly erasers there are
other codes that are small and pretty
efficient that you can use to correct
the erasers
directly uh okay so that's uh led us to
kind of consider this uh this uh new way
of doing uh bosonic error correction uh
we're going to use a microwave cavity
we're going to add some complexity we're
now going to encode the cubit in a pair
of microwave cavities or microwave modes
that have uh let's say different spatial
and uh different uh frequency uh uh
different spatial modes and different
frequencies and uh the uh logical
encoding is that we're going to have an
exitation which is either uh in Alice
the uh left cavity or in uh Bob uh the
right cavity and uh that just gives us a
simple two-level uh system uh uh which
is your Cubit space and um the reason
this is uh important is now if the
predominant error that you're having is
uh of course the excitation which could
be either on the left or on the right
disappears then you will go to this
unique State 0 0 and in the story I'm
going to show you there's multiple ways
that you can then uh detect the fact
that the photon has been lost and you
can even do that without detecting
whether it was supposed to be on the
left or on the right um using mid
circuit
erasers uh and so there's a syndrome
here which means you can have uh a way
to detect these errors now um there's uh
a proposal paper uh that came out a
paper about the way in which to do the
gates and then uh this uh uh preprint on
the archive uh showing some of the uh
results on uh the basic properties of
these cubits that I'm going to describe
um so uh the Dual rail is not new to us
uh it's actually a very old idea uh goes
back uh to linear Optics of course and
proposal by uh Chang and Yamamoto in
just a couple of years after uh after
Shore um and uh there's many uh examples
of why you would want to make something
differential you have two things and you
look for the difference between them uh
and so uh there was proposal for doing
this dual rail with uh transmons from
Amazon there's also uh a pre-print uh
very contemporaneous from the Amazon
group uh demonstrating a dual rail using
transmons and then there are these
earlier proposals and work from will
Oliver's group uh uh as well so um uh
it's not that it's necessarily a unique
idea but I think the idea of doing it
using microwave cavities and trying to
leverage this further noise structure
you have of low def phasing uh could
prove to be uh more
advantageous so um here's the thing we
want to simplify our task of eror
Correction let's have something which
has a really nice structure to its uh
airor process es and what uh we you know
can do is use the physics we know of
circuit QED and these cavities to kind
of predict what the major types of
Errors should be and what their
frequency of occurrence uh might turn
out to be so uh the erasers are going to
be set by the T1 time that's the fastest
error process in the in the cavities so
you want your dominant error process to
be the best kind to be an
AER uh and so uh that might be on time
SC of a millisecond uh if you're going
to do Gates on uh sort of uh frequency
scales given by the dispersive coupling
to a transmon for instance uh or on
microsc time scales that means you might
have a sort of 10 the minus 3
probability of an erer per time step of
the future
computer uh def phasing again we said
okay that's going to be tens of
milliseconds so that'll be at least in
order of magnitude
suppressed uh now uh what's a bit flip
uh well uh because we have these two
cavities at different
frequencies uh essentially uh any linear
coupling just renormalizes the mode
frequencies so if you're not doing some
nonlinear process there's almost no way
for a 5 GHz Photon to move into a 6 gahz
cavity uh the only thing that it could
do is relax to the ground state and
maybe get heated back up and so that
process uh should be sort of uh on time
scales of minutes uh it would give parts
per million or parts per billion per
kind of characteristic time and like
heating out of even the two Photon space
or whatever leakage which is the worst
of all errors maybe just basically
effectively never happens or you can I I
think we can have a non-destructive way
of measuring for leakage here uh uh for
uh almost all the
processes uh so here's the full
architecture you want to have these two
cavities you need to be able to do
operations so you need a beam splitter
interaction between them uh that's going
to be provid divided by some joses and
parametric devices and then you're going
to have an Ancilla transmon which is now
going to be used to like load the
photons in to measure the resulting
State and to give you a interaction
between two of these dual rail cubits
when you need it and um the thing that
we describe in this in this concept
paper is that using all the things we've
developed over the last few years we
believe that it's possible to detect all
of the dominant errors in this system
the cavity loss uh and when you're using
the transmon the def phasing and the
relaxation of the transmon as well and
convert them into low probabilities of
erasers uh which makes them much easier
to deal with and that requires you to
use the sort of three-level transmon
trick uh okay so uh how do you do single
Cubit Gates uh you want to transfer from
uh left to right you need a beam
splitter interaction uh we can do this
parametrically uh uh using uh sort of of
tools taken from the amplifier wing of
the circuit QED Community uh and
applying them to the highq cavity domain
and one of the things that's nice is now
uh essentially your Lor frequency is the
difference in frequencies between the
two cavities and you go back to sort of
the standard thing of using amplitude
and phase of your single uh RF tone that
you adjust uh or two tones if you're
doing four- wave mixing uh uh but it
makes the kind of uh ideas of how you
control these things much simpler now um
shy said oh uh I told her or we tell her
that beam Splitters are easy I I felt
like I had to defend uh my
guys um and actually uh you know we
weren't thinking of necessarily the Dual
Rail and that we needed to have super
awesome beam Splitters um we did know
that for all sorts of bosonic air
correction things we would want to do we
would need better beam Splitters and so
we launched a couple of years ago three
or four separate projects looking at
different ways of getting better uh
interactions and two of them worked
pretty well actually almost equally well
and so we're not sure yet uh you know
which is kind of the preferred strategy
uh the first of these uh was to um use
this snail device pioneered in
Michelle's group here at Gale um and uh
biasing it to the right flux point where
you have predominantly three-wave mixing
because we think not necessarily
three-wave mixing is better than
four-wave mixing a priori but because if
you reduce the number of unwanted
processes that'll help you get a cleaner
interaction and so we figured out a way
to get sort of DC flux bias and RF drive
into one of these uh two mode uh post
cavity kinds of devices with this thing
that looks like the right flyer um and
um uh we could uh show sort of uh
parametric oscillations here between the
left and the right between Alice and Bob
uh that look like this and they look
sort of like a Robbie oscillation but
not uh because they're sort of falling
down toward uh toward the ground and
that's a good thing that's an important
sign uh what that means here is that
we're doing fast operations and that uh
predominantly we're preserving the nice
air structure of the cavities so we
might be adding a little bit of extra
relaxation but usually that's very small
uh but we're adding even less def
phasing def phasing would take you sort
of to something where the photon is in
one or the two boxes uh but you just
don't know where uh which one um but
here what's happening is really the
predominant thing is just that the
photon's being lost and that means we
can treat it as an
eraser uh the second scheme uh is using
uh this uh parity protection and sort of
flux pumping a uh a squid uh device
which is essentially a transmon but uh
pumped in a different uh way again this
is
not earth shattering uh groundbreaking
news for the amplifier Community it's
just us learning to do it in a way that
doesn't spoil the uh hundreds of microsc
to milliseconds lifetimes of these uh
devices and so again you can get very
nice uh swap oscillations between things
with this device we could go even a
little faster and get down to swap times
of like 100 NCS or beam splitter rates
of a couple of mehz
um and uh indeed this looks a bit like a
Robbie oscillation so we can treat it as
such and say let's just um see what we
can do if we change the amplitude in the
phase of this uh beam splitter uh such
that we do uh uh randomized benchmarking
on this uh block sphere formed by the
single exitation manifold of Alice and
Bob and uh uh What uh we could see is
something where we could do actually
thousands of gates uh the uh raw gate
infidelity here is uh something uh a
little bit better than
39 but again uh we're Falling Towards
the uh ground state here so we actually
can do a post selection we can measure
which ones of these randomized
benchmarking trials didn't suffer the
photon loss and see what the Fidelity is
in that case and in that case when we
just post select on the fact that we
have to have a photon in either Alice or
Bob we're throwing out about one in 1300
of the
operations um but it's improving the
Fidelity uh by a significant amount
actually the referee said what's the big
deal about a few uh tenth of a tenth of
a percent um it's a factor of four
Improvement so I'm sure they weren't in
this room uh there's a factor of four
Improvement in the overall Fidelity
which again is sort of confirming that
we're preserving the the uh uh noise
structure where Photon loss is the
dominant thing okay so um why are we
excited this is like two orders of
magnitude almost faster than we've been
able to go in other bosonic codes like
the binomial code um and also about two
orders of magnitude higher uh Fidelity
for doing single Cubit
operations
um okay so um now what I want to do is
uh uh switch by the way I'm sort of uh
indicating which lab did the experiments
with the little logo in the upper right
hand corner so now I want to switch and
tell you about uh using uh some very
precise measurements with these dual
rails to try and confirm more about this
error hierarchy and be more specific
about the phase flip and bit flip rates
and all that sort of stuff um so what
we're going to do here is an endof thee
line projective measurement of the uh
dual rail Cubit uh and we're going to be
able to build into it this uh eraser
detection so just as a reminder right so
you can do pretty good readout of
transmons these days uh you can read the
ground state very well uh typically the
uh Fidelity is limited by the fact that
a readout takes some 100 NCS to a
microsc and the T1 time then gives you
about a percent or so uh or maybe a few
tents of a percent uh uh probability
that you've actually relaxed during the
course of the measurement the real
problem here is that a single error like
a T1 during the measurement or a
misassignment of which blob you have in
your histogram leads to uh an incorrect
conclusion about the state of the Cubit
going in um now in the Dual rail there's
something really nice basically all you
ever have to do in state preparation and
measurement is deal with Fox States you
need to make n equals 1 in your cavity
and you need to measure n equals 0 or n
equals
1 uh and the dispersive interaction with
a transbond is just built for that that
right uh there may be a phase def
phasing back action when you do a
measurement of the photon number with a
transmon but it just doesn't matter if
you're doing a preparation in one of the
logical States or if you're doing a
measurement in one of the logical States
and so uh what you can do here is you
can have a transmon for instance on both
Alice and Bob and you can make a
measurement where you map whether
there's zero or one photons onto ground
or excited state of the transmon Ancilla
that's attached to those cavities and
then you perform a measurement of each
transmon you can do that in parallel and
you get two bits of
information um and those two bits of
information are going to tell you
whether you're in 0 one one0 which
logical State you're in but they can
also give you extra information right
they will oops um they will also tell
you for example whether uh you get uh a
z zero and then you can throw those out
so you're getting extra information but
also importantly you're getting uh
something which is now first order
insensitive to uh single error in this
process uh because you have to misassign
both of the cavities to the wrong photon
number in order to actually get confused
about the logical
State now maybe if you miss a photon n
equals 1 call it n equals 0 you think
you're in z0 and there was still a
photon around that's just some extra
eraser probability as long as that's
small enough that might be okay here
it's pretty big but we've been int
intentionally trying to optimize for the
best uh discrimination between The
Logical states to use this as a sort of
uh better microscope to look at the
coherence and so here are some of the
results that are in this uh in this
preprint um there's a sort of uh
preparing uh the zero and one and by the
way the preparation can be done
redundantly because you can prepare n
equals 1 and then use the transmon to
check and only go forward when both
cavities have been correctly assigned to
zero or one whatever you wanted them to
to be uh we have a a model that takes
into account all the coherences of the
system and seems to do a pretty good job
of uh uh predicting things and so when
you try to prepare let's say uh one or
the other of the two logical States
there's some probability that you either
uh actually or in falsely get a uh uh
think that you've had in AER but if
you're in the code space uh it seems
like you're getting it correct at the
couple of parts in 10 the four so you
only misassign your logical State sort
of 10 or 20 times out of
100,000 um and that's uh quite a lot uh
better than uh the typical readouts that
one can
do uh okay so um as I said now this
means that we can separate out the
different error mechanisms within uh
this dual Rail and we can try and look
at whether it's going to actually
fulfill uh these predictions about the
hierarchy of the uh error rates and uh
uh and uh the future performance you
might get so um here let's create a
superp position uh we do that by loading
a photon into one cavity doing a pi over
two uh 50/50 beam splitter uh pulse
parametrically and then uh delaying for
some amount of time for uh particular
reasons we're doing an echo in the
middle and then uh doing a pi over 2 at
the end uh after that and then at the
end you do this projective measure
a logical basis and throw away all the
things that are uh erased the purple
here shows you the probability that
you've been erased that's just growing
uh at a time scale of a few hundred
micros seconds which corresponds to the
T1 lifetime of the 3D cavities that are
used here um and what you can see here
is Ramsey fringes or Echo fringes and
they persist out uh you know past sort
of uh the characteristic time scale
associated with the eraser because these
are keeping only the shots that are
still in the logical code space um and
so this is ramsy uh this is Echo um and
the time scales here are pretty long
what I also find amazing about this is
like if we just zoom in here on the
short time uh meaning the first 20
microseconds of this dual rail
Cubit uh there's no adjustment here in
the contrast there's uh just this is
taking the raw sh
uh so um what you can see here is that
you have resolution that allows you to
say okay uh we're only getting a few
parts in 10 to the three uh decrease of
our Ramsey contrast or our Echo contrast
after 10 micros so the probability of a
phase flip happening is uh something
like 2 * 10us 4 uh in uh a microsc which
is kind of the time scale we're going to
be interested in for doing Gates and the
like um and so that places again a bound
on the def phasing uh that says we're at
least bigger than a couple of
milliseconds in this case I think we
still haven't seen the bottom here so
there can be other exogenous effects
that look like def phasing um and you
know there's also uh potentially issues
with just uh even though the measurement
is very good deconvolving the
measurement precisely uh is is a good
question uh okay um now uh I said that
even after you've gotten rid of the
erasers there's supposed to be a strong
hierarchy between bit flips and phase
flips which again can be advantageous at
least if you're just having the cubits
idling and sitting around so uh we can
look at sort of the bit flip rate by
either preparing one of the two logical
States and uh then uh as a function of
uh time uh looking to see the
probability that you stay in the uh you
think you stayed in the uh initial
logical State uh and um this is actually
polluted here by the fact that as the
erasers become of order one uh then or
start Rising here it's just getting up
to uh uh sorry it's over here yeah
eraser is getting up to about of order
one now any small probability that you
take the erased State and assign it to
be the wrong logical State can kind of
dominate but again you see that these uh
uh curves are quite flat um so uh we can
place a bound here that the bit flip
lifetime is something like uh you know
50 to 100
milliseconds um I mentioned that the bit
flip should be dominated by uh uh
relaxation and then Heating in a
separate experiment we can measure the
heating rate the excited state thermal
equilibrium population of these cavities
is about 10us 3 or 10us 4 so the actual
bit flip lifetime we would predict is
something like 15
minutes okay enough that it just doesn't
matter right
uh at least when you're
idling uh okay so um then let me uh
guess they didn't give me a strict time
limit so I'm going to take uh uh take a
privilege and uh go go slowly and uh
finish off with a few things here so um
I mentioned that you want to not only be
able to do uh a detection of the photon
loss at the end but you also want to be
able to check for erasers during uh an
operation and you want to do that in a
way that's not also going to perturb The
Logical state so uh if we wanted to
measure a change in photon number or uh
a photon loss in one of the usual
bosonic codes what we would do is
monitor the cavity
parity here to detect whether there's a
photon lost from either Alice or Bob
what we need to do is measure the joint
photon number parity or we want to know
whether the system is in Z 0 and so uh
there's a way to do that even if you
only have a transmon attached to one of
the two cavities and the reason for that
is when we drive a beam splitter what
we're doing is swapping the photon back
and forth so if you like the transmon is
sensing both the photons that started in
Alice and the photons that started in
Bob or uh it's effectively making these
two uh distinct modes look
indistinguishable okay uh and so uh I'll
show you some uh very recent results
from Stein degraph and Sophia shu who's
in the audience um uh St to think is out
with something uh but uh uh what I'm
going to show you here is uh joint
photon number
splitting so uh What uh uh they do is um
basically we just can look at the
Spectrum of the transmon here as a
function of frequency uh and the sort of
probability that you get excited uh and
so just do spectroscopy of the transmon
whoops uh while um uh you change the
beam splitter rate and to start with uh
if we just are in the vacuum you know
there's just one Peak this is not
surprising uh but if you start with uh
one Photon in the system somewhere uh
and You Begin driving uh the beam
splitter what you see is uh that here
there are sort of uh two peaks that are
offset and uh as you drive the beam
splitter harder and harder uh the states
kind of evolve as I said you're making
things kind of go from originally left
and right and you're turning these on
you're getting these sort of symmetric
and anti-symmetric combinations and so
now the plus and the minus State uh or
what was left and right are are uh no
longer distinguishable it's probably not
the best this the first time I'm
explaining this so it's probably not the
best way uh but uh what you can also see
here in the spectrum is this faint line
that comes from uh the residual 0000
population that's the Peak at which the
transmon would be excited if you had no
photons in the system
and so to do a check for Erasers on the
Fly what you do is just a spectroscopic
pulse uh about that frequency which
takes a time of order Kai or Kai over
two actually uh because you're only
sensing the photons half the time and so
uh we'll drive with a beam splitter here
which is on the order of Kai uh the
dispersive coupling and uh look at what
results and so uh here is uh sort of
performing a pairs of these eraser
checks uh if we start with a
superposition uh you can see the
following kinds of things so there's
some probability that uh per check uh
you have uh an eraser actually occurring
that's the green line there's some uh
increased probability of falsely
declaring an eraser so that's something
like 4% per check but then if you look
at the decay of the uh zogical
information it's pretty slow in fact it
actually seems to improve the contrast
of the Ramsey uh so we can infer from
that that there's sort of a few ten
percent probability of inducing a phase
flip uh per one of these eraser checks
and you can also do the same thing to
look at the bit flip rate uh uh per
check this doesn't come uh because of
heating or something like that but
because you're swapping many times uh
and you need to make sure you've done
the swaps precisely enough so uh a
little bit uh the uh uh phase of the
beam splitter or the Precision of the
beam splitter turns into something that
looks like bad flips uh okay so um this
kind of thing is the Primitive that you
need for doing two Cubit Gates um and so
uh again in these uh concept papers uh
we describe a way of doing the gates
what you need to do if you want to do uh
an entangling operation between two of
these dual rails is engineer some kind
of an interaction between them and so if
the uh two individual dual rails here
share a a beam beam splitter and you
drive that beam splitter you can
effectively measure the joint parity of
these two which will depend on uh not
whether you're erased but on which
logical States the two cubits were in
and you can make this kind of
exponentiation Gadget where the transmon
will end up in the ground state at the
end uh provided you did everything right
and you impart a a a zz phase on this
pair of uh cubits and of course the
transmon now is being used to give you
the nonlinearity to sort of engineer
this Cur the downside is you're
suffering from transmon decoherence but
with the three-level transmon by
detecting the transmon at the end both
uh uh relaxation and Def phasing can be
uh found and turned into erasers and so
uh uh we get a sort of a flag just like
you would want not only of when a
cubit's been erased but when a gate goes
wrong uh and uh we can classify that as
well as an eraser although would be an
eraser now on a pair of cubits um so uh
if one just puts in kind of typical
coherence times and typical dispersive
couplings that means this gate will take
on the order of a microsc or two um and
the eras errors should be on the percent
level that's kind of like the standard
problem everyone has uh but uh the
residual P errors come from sort of
second order things or the intrinsic def
phasing rate of the cavity and we think
those even be on the order of 10us 4 and
so now you don't want to talk about the
Fidelity you have to talk about multiple
kinds of fidelities what's the
probability of this eraser error
occurring which is easier to deal with
than the probability of a poly error
occurring and uh again uh these eraser
errors they uh can be corrected more
rapidly and they have a higher threshold
and so uh together with shruti's uh Team
uh we've done some simulations for uh
this system by the way uh that means
that if you have maybe I should go back
for one sec having a factor of 100
between these is kind of nice uh because
it means that essentially you're gaining
even with your uh sort of factor of five
or 10 past the uh eraser threshold
something like beating the traditional
surface code threshold by a factor of
100 um so you'd sort of like to have
these things uh uh spaced out in this
nice way
uh so um if we do some uh simulations
with kind of typical coherence
properties and you can get atio rates on
the order of a percent or maybe a little
bit less than a percent and you really
can get p erors on the order of 10us 4
even though you're post selecting on all
the gates that went wrong the surface
code can correct for that and give you
something which in principle should have
an error correction gain of something
like uh one to two orders of magnitude
per layer so that's feels like something
that's actually worth building into a
code and scaling up um so the sort of
lesson here if you didn't take away any
of the details is that there's a cheat
uh error detection is kind of a way to
bootstrap yourself potentially towards
full error correction um so uh that's I
think quite amazing and something I
learned again from from shy and Jeff um
so can you make this thing into a
surface code yes you could it's not a
small part count so that might not be uh
an RSL uh job but um you only need
actually coordination uh three between
your individual cavities to give you
sort of a 2d grid of these uh uh dual
rails and you also don't need a transmon
on every uh site as shy was saying you
can sprinkle them around you might only
even need transmons on your measure
cubits in the surface code for instance
and again you can also use other smaller
codes uh 3D cavities are not the only
thing um
uh inspired by the kind of work you just
heard about from Natalie and working
together with Natalie and and Andrew's
team uh we have replicated this tantalum
process and uh in this uh preprint from
my student suas uh we uh demonstrated
that we could sort of have a budget that
predicts why a hybrid transmon is about
300 microsc but also why a uh onchip
resonator made of tantalum should always
beat
the Joseph injunction basically you can
have a lower surface participation ratio
so uh you don't have to think of linear
resonators is only the 3D things no
matter what materials you have what form
factor you make you should always be
able to make a longer T1 and a much
longer t for a linear resonator so
that's maybe the reason why you might
want to do these things and so uh the
fact that these are always longer and
that this now becomes a little bit more
modular and easier to scale uh sort of
looks like a very nice thing as well
okay so uh thanks for indulging me I'm
not sure how long I went on um uh I
wanted to thank the entire team uh so uh
both uh on campus uh and at qci and
thank very much uh shuy and Steve and
maybe I will just leave uh some
conclusions and uh summary here and take
any questions
[Applause]
thanks
there's a
couple so uh this of course it's a very
nice talk uh and this is very exciting
this new type of error correction um in
the cat code paper of Nissim and Andre
there was a optimization that had to be
done on how frequently you do the
measurement and checking how does that
work here um yeah so I don't know that I
understand all of the details of that
yet um uh let me go back to the mid
circuit check so um you know if you're
trying to correct for these aers uh in a
higher level code um and not just do
Post selection then you have to
interrogate and perform this check you'd
like to do the check as frequently as
you can and it matters what the back
action is right and so uh these sort of
uh bit flip and phase flip probabilities
per check are the kinds of things that
uh will enter in and there's going to be
some optimal measurement strategy
depending on the T1 of your cavity and
so on um but uh you know in the sort of
cat code you're basically exciting the
transmon 100% the whole time in this
spectroscopic thing you're just exciting
it primarily uh when you've already had
an eraser and so you then don't care
about the kind of back action that
limited the cat code uh uh uh but in
addition sort of Kai T1 in that
experiment was something like 20 I think
and so here effectively it's getting up
towards uh a larger number like 500
maybe um so stay tuned that's an
interesting
question I think that trade-off is
Universal no matter what you're doing in
error
correction so the uh the very top of
sh's pyramid was biased erasers and I
guess you don't have any uh biased
erasers here because your encoding is 01
and one
Z is is there anything like are you just
so far out that it doesn't matter or is
there anything to gain from trying to
come up with a new coding scheme where
you can have right uh so indeed bias
erasers can buy you another what is it
factor of two or so in the
threshold um I don't know of a way to
have biased erasers for just the cavity
Photon loss uh I do think it may be
possible to get biased erasers for the
gate uh
errors basically you can figure out
where the cubits were based on uh what
you see uh after the transmon has caused
a problem well if you had I guess if you
had a logical space that was I don't
know two and 1 one or something
silly wouldn't that be a biased toer
because then you would Decay out of the
two stay it
faster yes but what you want is
something where
um yeah okay but maybe you're just
making um you want biased erasers but
you don't want to get biased erasers by
making one of the rates
faster you want to make one of you know
the one of the rates go to zero right um
so uh that's another aspect in which I
think the Dual rail is kind of one of
these happy surprises uh you know you
only need one Photon so the overhead in
terms of the uh how many times Kappa is
uh pretty minimal um so uh
so this is a really cool um cool work
post selection is also the domain of
weird physics like anomalous weak values
and nonan hamiltonians and do you get
weird effects from those things and or
can you use like weak value
amplification to make errors I haven't
thought about the weak value
amplification there is one uh bug that a
dual rail has that's sort of non-h
herian so if your cavity lifetimes are
not
equivalent then uh if you wait around
long enough you will uh almost certainly
be in whichever of the two cavities had
the slightly longer lifetime um it turns
out that uh kind of evolution though is
uh sort of deterministic so uh if you
just make sure that you have an echo
pulse midway between when you're using
things uh then you spend just as much
time in each of the logical states with
the exitation in each of the physical
cavities and in fact we see that that uh
can sort of undo this no jump back
action that you get um and you know
there's other reasons why it's nice to
have echoes in everybody's uh things so
I think that's not much of a penalty
cool
but if you have other ideas about what
to do you should
talk okay if we don't have any more
question let thanks throw
again okay
uh I think it's going to be then up to
me to close the conference so before you
guys get up I'd love to thank all of the
speakers this has been an amazing
meeting thank you all for
coming
[Music]